what is the area of the shaded figure
so down here we have this green shaded
figure
and it looks like a rectangle
except it has this square cut out in the
middle
so when we find its area we can think of
it exactly like that we want to know how
much space it covers it covers this
rectangle's amount of area
with this square cut out
so what we can do is find the area of
the larger rectangle
and then cut out or subtract
the area of the square to see what's
left in this shaded area
so
let's start
by finding the area
of this larger rectangle
and to do that we can look at the side
lengths
it has a side side lengths of 9 and 8.
to find area of a rectangle we can
multiply the side length
so 9 times 8 is 72
so that means that this rectangle covers
72 square centimeters this entire
rectangular area
covers 72 square centimeters
but now
we need to cut out or subtract
the area of this square
because that's not part of our shaded
figure we need to cut that part out
so to do that we know the side lengths
are four on the square so we can think
of this
as this is four centimeters across so we
can divide it into four equal sections
and same going
this way
and then if we connect these lines
what it will show us
is that we have it's not drawn perfect
but we have four rows
of four square centimeters four times we
see four square centimeters this top row
one two three four and so on four rows
so there's 16 square centimeters we need
to cut out of the 72 of this entire
rectangular area we need to cut out or
subtract 16 of these square centimeters
so let's do that
we have 72 is the entire area and then
let's start subtracting half we subtract
out 10 of them just because for me i
like subtracting 10s because they're
simpler
so 4
10 of the square centimeters
now we're down to an area of 62 left
and then let's subtract those two more
will get us to subtract two more will
get us to sixty
and then there's four left to subtract
in order to subtract all 16 so 60 minus
four gets us to
56.
so the entire area of 72
we subtracted out these 16 square
centimeters
leaves us with a final area of 56
square
centimeters